langsam ist es schon ein bisschen so als
würden sich die indizien verdichten
der mars rover curiosity hat erhebliche
mengen organischen materials auf dem
mars gefunden
und inzwischen ist das ja einer von
vielen kunden die leben früher oder
sogar noch heute auf dem mars bedeuten
könnten also was ist los auf dem mars
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
ich muss jetzt doch noch mal eine dicke
lanze für die whatsapp community brechen
inzwischen kommen die themenvorschläge
da am laufenden band rein und bevor ich
ein thema finde hat sie irgendjemand aus
der community bereits gefunden auf dem
disco zwar sind alle unglaublich aktiv
und es gibt jetzt sogar eigene christoph
images für jede stimmungslage ja vielen
dank an christoph und slawistik und der
absolute hammer
heute erreichen wir 20.000 voller das
ist eine der größten reichweiten auf
wozzeck von einem youtuber und ich freue
mich über jeden und jede die dabei ist
wenn du das videos gibt es den link dazu
es geht mit einem einfachen klick ja so
was ist also auf dem maßlos wir hatten
ja schon so die ein oder andere meldung
wasser viel wasser wasser direkt unter
der oberfläche einen fund der sehr
verdächtig nach einem lebewesen oder in
den spuren eines lebewesens aussah
methan was hier auf der erde als
indikator für leben gilt usw
es gibt einfach immer mehr indizien für
leben auf dem mars und jetzt das der
mars rover curiosity der nasa hat auf
der marsoberfläche komplexe organische
moleküle gefunden die gleichen kilo
gehen dass hier auf der erde in erdöl
und erdgas enthalten ist und
biologischen ursprungs ist und curiosity
hat davon 100 mal mehr gefunden als
bisher
die forschungsgruppe vermutet einen
geologischen ursprung kann aber einen
biologischen nicht ausschließen
sie vermuten dass es nicht aus einem
meteoriten stand womit die herkunft der
mars wäre das wiederum nährt die
hoffnung dass ist biologischen ursprungs
sein könnte was wirklich krasses genau
an dieser stelle war vor milliarden
jahren ein see einen zuverlässigen
nachweis ob das material biologischen
oder biologischen ursprungs ist kann
klose 10 nicht erbringen vielleicht ist
das noch mal mehr anreiz möglichst bald
weitere missionen zum mars zu schicken
die proben auch wieder zurück zur erde
schicken können oder ihnen mars ist
schneller
ja das wird hochspannend erstmal ist
jetzt exomars an die sonde der
europäischen weltraumagentur esa wird
sich in tiefen gesteinsschichten bohren
und weitere erkennt
sie bringen es bleibt also spannend auf
dem mars wenn ihr kein video dazu und zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt die
youtuber box die funktioniert ja nicht
dann endet mich bei whatsapp nur dann
verpasst ihr kein video und über
whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir auch vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantiert und zur begrüßung habe ich
ein kleines geschenk für euch einfach
hier draufklicken und lasst uns sollte
die 20.000 voll ohrmarke reisen ja und
am besten auch how to music abonnieren
das produzieren wir ja für funk und
heute ist unser erstes musikvideo online
gegangen also dafür hier klicken aber
nicht die genau die glocke vergessen und
hier dafür auch draufklicken da geht es
um musik video und ich bin gespannt was
haltet ihr davon
in swatch gerne die videos von auto
musik bis dann bleibt dran